this is the new headquarters of the
European Central Bank the building
stands over 185 meters tall and is
subject to strict security we're joining
a guided tour for journalists to get a
look inside a rare privilege done in
Vermont okay let's get started please
watch out for construction vehicles and
builders remember it's still a building
sites did it the towers of the new
central bank have been incorporated into
a former indoor market that has
protected status because it's a historic
building it's been totally transformed
on the inside the new way provides a
suitably impressive entrance while work
on the grounds is still continuing
inside workers are busy painting the
walls and installing the many technical
features the new headquarters have cost
1.3 billion euros to build that's 50%
more than originally budgeted
the upstairs area of the old indoor
market now houses the conference center
it can host up to 12 meetings at a time
Monday in our meetings may run for eight
or ten hours or even two days that
breaks of course when that muth so the
rooms have to be suitable tasters and
one is in particular needs to be a good
air circulation going to push a roof it
must be too warm or too loud stuff has
no noise from outside when Allison next
we meet the architect how did he
conceived the building does the design
reflect the ECB's mandate it's it you
can get into hot water if you start
drawing comparisons like that but then
the architect does dare to draw a
comparison dissing its way to admit
there are two towers joined by an atrium
the lion in the two towers wouldn't be
able to stand on their own two partners
stabilized each other and together they
form one tower so you could say that
reflects European monetary policy
patient okayed like politics Atul some
employees have already moved in the rest
are to follow in November 2009 hundred
people will then be working here but
despite its impressive size the new
building is actually too small for the
ECB's now expanded duties the klingon
lawyer of cabinets we've been given a
new task which is to monitor banks
across europe the people responsible for
that will stay in the city centre don't
move into the euro tower
in other words they won't be here at the
ECB headquarters there just isn't room
for them that new division alone has
around a thousand employees the plan
alone fit is gabor de planning for this
building began in 2001 obviously the
planners looked repeatedly at how the
ECB was growing and what changes were
needed but no one foresaw the bank
receiving such a huge new task in the
immediate future
the odds were coming up at the end of
our tour we head up to the 42nd floor
and the meeting room of the ECB
Executive Board it's framed by windows
on three sides at re o Draghi will sit
in the center opposite the main entrance
to decides one journalist tries out the
ECB president's chair the decisions made
in this room will determine the future
of the euro that's what I've got
something and that's important stuff
have adequate measures been taken to
prevent others listening in say my
manhood I can't talk about that but
there is a foolproof system but saying
the other illnesses that so nothing can
go wrong no comment
instead the architects explains the
design of the ceiling it shows a
distorted map of Europe what's the
upside money as much as it was never our
intention that the map of Europe would
be directly recognizable to Ithaca but
that it should arouse curiosity where
you ask yourself what is that on the
ceiling
what is that wave-like cloud-like
structure now of course you could read
something into that but we don't see
dark clouds we see Europe I'm guessing
Hopa Europe is nevertheless going
through turbulent times the debt crisis
continues and banks across Europe are
now subject to closer monitoring it's
the ECB's job to keep the overview and
steer Europe's financial markets into
calmer waters